[Music]
oh there she is there she's
nice pose the house down chi
chi devine has died the rupaul's drag
race star was 34.
no cause of death has been officially
released but chichi had been
hospitalized
several times in recent months sharing
this message on instagram over the
weekend
[Music]
chichi was suffering from pneumonia and
suspected kidney
failure stemming from a chronic tissue
disease
in july chichi shared this message from
the hospital
tomorrow they're going to give me a
biopsy on my kidneys
and let me know
what it is that's making blood pressure
so high
chi-chi starred on two seasons of
rupaul's drag race becoming one of the
franchise's
fan favorite performers rupaul told et
in a statement quote
i am heartbroken to learn of the passing
of chi-chi devayne
i am so grateful that we got to
experience her kind and beautiful soul
she will be dearly missed but never
forgotten may her generous and loving
spirit shine down on all
of us on behalf of vh1 world of wonder
and the cast and crew of rupaul's drag
race i extend my deepest sympathy
from our family to hers several people
from the drag race family took to social
media to mourn her passing
trixie mattel tweeted an iconic queen
literally
everyone in our industry will always
love chi-chi's season 8 drag race
co-star bob the drag queen wrote on
instagram
i'm truly devastated what do you have to
say to little
xavier i would tell little xavier
davenport
that it doesn't matter where you're from
and how you grew up the neighborhood you
grew up in that has
nothing to do with how far you can go
never be ashamed of how you walk talk
because that is going to be the key to
your success
you